what we're concerned with in my
day-to-day work these days is the
security of the Internet you come to
think of it it's absolutely everywhere
and it's not just between you and a
website it's also in the cloud it's also
in all sorts of software and the big
awakening is that for the past 20 years
this has never been secure and the
consequences are so huge there's so much
at stake that people are ready to try
something different you're listening to
the Microsoft Research podcast a show
that brings you closer to the cutting
edge of technology research and the
scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen heusinger when
people first started making software
computers were relatively rare and there
was no internet so programming languages
were designed to get the job done
quickly and run efficiently with little
thought for security but software is
everywhere now from our desktops to our
cars from the cloud to the Internet of
Things
that's why dr. Jonathan protsenko a
researcher in the rise or research in
software engineering group at Microsoft
Research is working on designing better
software tools in order to make our
growing software ecosystem safer and
more secure today dr. protsenko talks
about what's wrong with software and why
it's vitally important to get it right
explains why there are so many
programming languages and tells us about
a few he's been working on and finally
acts as our digital Sherpa for project
everest an assault on software integrity
and confidentiality that aims to build
and deploy a verified HTTP stack that
and much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
johnathan protsenko welcome to the
podcast
hi your researcher in the rise or
research in software engineering group
one of the big problems you're trying to
solve I usually ask my guests what gets
you up in the morning but I can't help
myself what makes you rise and shine
well I rise is focused with many aspects
of software engineering and the specific
thing that I'm concerned with is
programming languages and what gets me
up in the morning is the fact that
there's a lot of software out there that
needs us to intervene into something
about I was recently seeing an ad for a
pet feeder that has a camera and that
can report to me in my smartphone and
the immediate thing that I thought about
was that's going to be a security
failure and soon enough there will be
videos of my cat over the Internet
it's not a huge deal but when you think
about the millions of devices that are
out there and they're ready to be hacked
and they're ready to be covered by the
New York Times in the next wave of
cyberattacks and very concerned about
the state of the software ecosystem and
in rise what we're trying to do is
address problems related to software
through research and trying to make
software better in general before we
plunge into the specific research you're
doing I do want to talk about
programming languages in general to
paraphrase a colleague of yours Ben Zorn
from a software perspective you build
the things people build things with yes
and there wouldn't be any big technical
revolutions if there weren't programming
languages that said there are so many of
them they're legion why are there so
many so it's actually a good question
there have been like hundreds if not
thousands of programming languages being
developed and there's always new ones
popping up I think one of the reasons is
there's that holy grail of programming
languages that you're always seeking the
right programming language that will
compromise on nothing the one that will
allow you to get the speed that you want
the programmer productivity that you
want and also zero bugs and I don't
think we've attained that holy grail yet
so the quest continues
there's always room for improvement you
realize that there exists large
ecosystems of software and that we're
now reaching like millions hundreds of
millions of lines of code and any
improvement in the tool that you use
every single day of your life is going
to be an improvement over software in
general so the responsibility is
enormous in a sense we have to design
the right tools that will make people
write better tools for other people so I
usually frame my more general questions
from what I like to call the ten
thousand foot view but since we're gonna
land on Everest in this podcast I'll
frame it from the twenty nine thousandth
of you alright let's talk about software
verification and security writ large
these are the kind of reasons for being
or the ways on that for you guys give us
an overview of what's wrong here and why
it's important to get it right in what
you're doing with the research to tackle
this so it kind of ties it into what we
were mentioning earlier there's a lot of
software that's absolutely critical
we're either gigantic breaches of
security or at stake or human lives or
accidents and there's usually a large
set of examples that you can draw from
ranging from DNA testing software to
planes to nuclear software medical
devices it's a very large array and
there are I think a few of these areas
where we've hit the right spot and buy
the right spot I mean that the
consequences are so dramatic and the
past incidents have been so wide-ranging
and have had such an impact that the
people in the field are ready to try
something different I think for instance
for medical devices were nearly getting
there
there have been hackable pacemakers
there have been demonstrations that you
can actually control someone's medical
device at a distance and I think for
instance in this specific configuration
soon enough people will realize that the
previous approaches no longer work that
they need to try something different and
that they need to start from the ground
up and actually think about how to write
better software and in our case and what
we're concerned with in my day to day
work these days is the security of the
internet you come to think of it it's
absolutely everywhere and it's not just
between you and a website it's also in
the cloud it's also in all sorts of
software
and the big awakening is that for the
past 20 years this has never been
secured and the consequences are so huge
there's so much at stake that people are
ready to try something different they
might be willing to let go of the
technology from the 70s that I was
mentioning and try something a little
strange
although functional but that might give
them greater confidence that maybe there
won't be a huge failure after all this
technology from the 70s you're referring
to I'm thinking of the C programming
language ah that remains the language
that people used to write the majority
of the software and it's extremely easy
to shoot yourself in the foot with that
language so what we're trying to do and
we're working with some great people is
to say this has been so broken and so
badly that we have a new methodology let
us try to help you that cares how we're
going to do it what do you think how
much of an education curve is this
requiring it's an extremely steep curve
and I think that's also a big challenge
in my field like how can we make these
tools usable by people outside of our
field there's a reason why people stick
with these well-established programming
languages is because they're very usable
and I think the tools that we use to
write more secure software are sometimes
not so usable or require like a very
high degree of training yeah that's also
a challenge for us like how can we make
software verification more usable for
someone that doesn't have that
background yeah that trade-off between
power and ease of use absolutely and
that's why new languages keep showing up
it's because sometimes you're ready to
have an expert that is going to use a
language that will make them very
productive but maybe you can find 10,000
experts or maybe your software is
already written and you can't swap it
out and we write everything from the
ground up oh wow my mind is just reeling
because I've had a couple of
cryptographers in the booth here and the
revelation that things aren't as secure
as you think I mean even if you go to an
HTTP not an HTTPS most people don't even
know that there's a difference there and
I'm talking about the vast majority of
people that are using the software yes
and that's why we need to help these
people because we can't read
the fact that people are gonna check the
padlock on your website it's just too
much to ask from a regular user so we
need to help them out and there's been
really great initiatives the number of
people who use HTTPS is skyrocketing in
no small part due to an initiative
called let's encrypt from it solid that
is nudging people to switch to HTTPS
nice and that has achieved really
excellent results and so if on top of
that we hope to give them more secure
software to perform as she TPS then I
think the world would be a slightly
better place or maybe even more than
slightly you're being modest because
like you said software is pervasive and
we're all just sort of onboarding it
into our lives the trend is that
software's going to be everywhere and
we're delegating extremely important
decisions to software when you think
about cars for instance and the millions
tens maybe hundreds of millions of lines
of code that are running in a car
it's just frightening and you see these
videos on YouTube of people taking
remote control of the car and it's not
just cars it's absolutely everywhere and
we're just putting an enormous amount of
stress into it and we will come back in
a while to what keeps you up at night
but let's get happy for a minute yes
let's talk about the cool projects
you're working on or have worked on and
one of them is a language a functional
language called F star yes and I keep
looking at it going F sharp it's a star
and it's a general-purpose functional
programming language with effects aimed
at program verification yes
so if Sarah draws inspiration from F
sharp tends to similar name and also the
general like family of functional
programming languages such as Oh camel
and the general ml family but it adds
verification on top of it the idea is
that if you're a functionally trained
programmer and you're comfortable with
ml maybe you've written a bunch of a
camel in your life here's a language
that allows you to go further and to
start thinking about what your programs
do what their specification is to reason
about them using printers conditions and
to generally use the assistance of an
SMPS over to scale at verification so in
that sense I think that F star is also
at a very interesting point in
design space and that it's trying to
cater to an audience of people who want
to write software first it's not a tool
that you would use to do a massive
mathematical proof about some theorem
but it's a tool that you would use to
write your software in mmm-hmm
who's your audience for this it's
actually a good question
a good way to think about it at is to
look at who's been working on our star
stars a large joint project the print
shot of Nick Swamy and a lot of his
collaborators including
inria and many other institutions and I
would say that the audience is academics
that are trying to write verified
software it can be both for learners
master students PhD students who are
warming up to verification it can be for
people who want to write a verified
piece of code that they're hoping to
land into some existing software and I'm
sure we'll talk about that soon yeah
what we're hoping our audience is is the
enlightened programmer someone who's
functionally trained realizes that it's
great but that there's also something
beyond that and who's willing to learn
more and go further and deeper to
actually convince themselves that their
software is doing the right thing
[Music]
so another thing you're working on is
called Kremlin I'm gonna spell this big
k little R little e big M big al little
I little N yes
why did that change up in lowercase
uppercase well just wanted to highlight
ml I like puns but all jokes aside the
interesting bit that you see in Kremlin
is that there's knr and ml and it's kind
of you know Kernighan and Ritchie meets
ml Kremlin is a compiler from F star to
C and here I'm tying together two things
that we talked about before the fact
that you want to use a high end
sophisticated advanced programming
language to prove important things about
your software but also the fact that the
majority of software these days is
written in C and that it's not going
away anytime soon and one interesting
thing is that you need to meet software
where it is so the idea behind my work
these days is that we need to reconcile
these two visions the vision of the
enlightened programmer that works in F
star and thus they're very advanced
verification result and the fact that
people want C code if you want your
software to be used and so Kremlin is a
compiler that will transform a subset of
F star into C code that is ready to be
integrated into existing software and
you can use all of F star you can write
code as you normally would you can
conduct proofs that are just like you
would normally accept that at the end of
the tool chain you get C code and you
can walk to people and say hey now I
have code that you might want to use
speaking of acronyms there's another
program you're working on called Hackel
star h AC l stands for high assurance
cryptographic library what is that and
what does it allow you to do what's cool
about this particular project so we
talked about how there exists that
programming language called F star and
the companion compiler that will give
you C code that people actually want to
use and once you have a tool chain the
question is how do you make the best use
of it and I've mentioned that there's a
lot of software disasters and in my
opinion cryptography is one of the
biggest ones because it's the
underpinning of almost every secure
software and if cryptography breaks your
whole scaffolding breaks
and everything shatters and so
cryptography is perhaps the place where
we have the right combination of factors
that make people want to use different
software new software verified software
mmm and so heckle stories are answer to
that it's a library of cryptographic
code verified in F star that comes out
of has a bunch of C code that people
want to use it's been designed in
collaboration with an RIA the French
Institute for computer science and it's
already been used by several people
what's the Venn diagram overlap with
cryptographers and programming language
people there's a lot of layers of people
working on different things and then
needing to get together and make it
usable there's the cryptographers that
design algorithms and for me that's not
my job I know that algorithms exist I
know how they're done but I wouldn't
have a really hard time creating a new
one so don't let me do that that could
be a disaster there's us the people who
implement the cryptography taking a
reference or a design or some math on a
paper that describes the inner workings
of an algorithm we just transform it
into actual software and then there's
the consumers people who know that they
need cryptography and are going to make
use of it in their own software and
we're kind of bridging the gap between
the cryptographers and the consumers by
taking existing implementations that
have been done before but Rivera fiying
them so we don't design new code what we
design is verification methodologies
that will allow us to show that either
the existing code was broken and we
found broken code or that the existing
code or our code is fine and that we're
ready to give it to consumers and we
were crucified with our consumers such
as Firefox and we spent a lot of time
making sure that the C code that comes
out of our tool chain is something that
they actually want to use and that
turned out to be surprisingly difficult
the question just in my head when you
said that is how hard is this so there's
two halves to the work in a sense like
first you want to verify code and that
is tedious difficult but in a sense we
already know that we're going to make it
it's just a matter of throwing enough
energy at it but then once you've done
that
actually going to meet people in
software telling them that you have
something new that really they should
use it it's a different problem and you
need to build trust you need to show
them that you're serious you need to
show them that you could make sense
they're probably not going to trust
you're very exotic verification
methodology and you're going to reread
the C code that comes out of it just to
convince themselves that it makes sense
so we spent a lot of time and energy
engaging with them polishing what comes
out of our verification suite and making
sure that it was something that looked
solid to them so let's talk about meet
Els a verified reference implementation
of TLS once you give us a little bit of
history of that project who's involved
in it what are you doing with it and why
do we need other organizations involved
in order to tackle this problem yes so
maybe I consider word about cialis first
please TLS is the protocol that you're
using when you're connecting to a
website over HTTPS and I was talking
about the cryptography being at the
bottom of the stack it's the base
building block but on top of the
cryptography you can work out a protocol
that will allow you to negotiate keys
parameters of sessions and then
establish a secure channel between you
and a third party so there's two key
properties that you want to establish
when you have a channel with a third
party integrity and confidentiality if
you're doing an o2
web search continentality is making sure
that no one can see what you're looking
for and integrity is making sure that no
one can tamper with your search while
you're receiving the results so the
protocol that does this is called TLS
who's previously known as SSL from the
early 90s originated at Netscape and
it's the one you use every time you go
to an HTTPS website and so me TLS is our
attempt at making TLS more secure it's a
fairly old project that started as a
joint collaboration between Microsoft
and INRIA hence my Microsoft in reality
is we've gone through successive
languages the first version of me TLS
was using a precursor of F star called
f7 and we've just evolved both the
verification artifact and the language
that enables us to verify the software
so the to go and then
we both designed the tools that enable
verification and take it upon ourselves
to actually use them to perform
verification and I would say that that's
the best way to design a tool is to use
it yourself
realize where you have shortcomings and
just try to fix it and improve it so
it's actually a continuous
back-and-forth process where you try to
verify something realize that the talk
will help you better or could do
something more easily for you and then
you fix a tool and the tool keeps
improving driven by the needs of the
verification so how much time do you
spend trying to break your stuff well
theoretically because it's verified it
should never be broken
so that's the theory and the practice is
we also try to find flaws and it's an
interesting question there's
occasionally flowers in our tools and we
need to either fix the tools improve the
tools or ideally verify the tools
themselves to show that our tools have
no flaws and also sometimes we don't
cover everything for instance you can
always write a very secure
implementation of TLS that just declines
to connect to any website when you get
the property that every connection is
secure so we also need to make sure that
we can actually interoperate with the
rest of the world
[Music]
now let's climb the big one be our
digital Sherpa on Project Everest your
goal I'll tee this up by saying your
goal is to build and deploy a verified
HTTP stack tell us all about Everest
so Everest is as you mentioned our
answer to that very sorry state of the
world which is that there hasn't been a
secure TLS implementation since the
beginning of TLS it's always broken so
what we set out to do a few years ago is
to say all right we've been working on
that me TLS technology can we push it
next level verify the entire stack and
also get people to use it so it was an
ambitious effort that we set out both in
terms of breath we want to verify the
entire stack and also in terms of impact
we want people to use it and so for that
we got together people at several
institutions
there's Microsoft Research here in
Redmond browser Cambridge in Bangalore
there's people at Carnegie Mellon
University and there's people at
University of Edinburgh and of course
there's our very close collaborators at
INRIA hmm and so what we're doing is
that it's so wide and big that we have
different people working on different
things Henry as I mentioned is mostly
concerned with the base building blocks
to cryptography we have another tool
that we use to verify assembly code for
those bits that really need absolute
performance and that's between say CMU n
here we have in Cambridge or expert
cartographers and protocol experts that
find the flaws and try to fix the
standard by submitting feedback whenever
they find a conceptual flaw in TNS and
we try to bring all these people
together behind that effort yeah all
right so Everest is a goal mountain for
a lot of people who climb would you
frame this as a goal mountain this
summit for software engineering I would
say that for us yes there's that theorem
that I was alluding to earlier that you
get integrity and confidentiality and
that's kind of the top of the pyramid
the summit of the mountain once we get
that theorem our entire stack will be
verified
we're hoping to get there and for us it
was to be a summit because it's a very
wide-ranging and ambitious verification
effort one thing to realize is that
we're aiming for a very comprehensive
set of software yeah just looking at the
cryptography we're aiming to verify not
just one algorithm but entire families
and we're aiming to offer a
comprehensive cryptographic library that
has everything you need to do crypto and
that covers all the popular algorithms
that you might need so it's a lot of
work it's a lot of software so I think
for us we're hoping that by the time we
reach that final theorem we will have
advanced both what we are capable of
doing in terms of size and also like the
state of the art in terms of
verification tools so what's the
relationship of me TLS with project
Everest me TLS is so far the main
component of project Everest and the one
that depends on almost everything else
and the one that will be our
implementation of TLS I think there will
be other things afterwards depends on
what you see at the top of the mountain
the top of the mountain could be meteor
S&C but it could also be see a verified
web server that uses materialized and
then were you know setting another goal
so I guess that remains to be determined
but yeah the v1 would be mission as in
the TLS library and maybe the v2 will
have other things such as a small server
or even other components of the stack
academics by nature are open-source
people you do some work you share it
with everybody
you build off the work of others and
they build off your work but that hasn't
necessarily historically been the case
in industry with IP and competitive
advantage issues but lately it seems
there's been a bit of a shift towards an
embrace of a more open-source mentality
so why do you think we're seeing more
sharing in the open-source community
among industry researchers and why is
that a good thing
so yes one thing that I should have
mentioned is that all of our work is
open-source and we work completely in
the open with academics and universities
all of our code is on github and we have
public discussion channels and I think
there's two aspects to consider the
first one is
we just work better when it's in the
open I find that it fosters better
collaborations more productive ideas and
generally a better atmosphere it's more
motivating to know that you're doing
software for the general good that will
benefit a lot of other people and just
software for a small subset of the
planet so that is something that
motivates me personally and I very much
believe in the societal value of having
code that is for everyone to use and the
other more pragmatic reason perhaps is
that in security if people can't see
your codes they're just going to have a
hard time convincing themselves that
you're secure so heart claim right that
your software is secure and you usually
want to provide evidence for that yeah
and if your code is closed source then
you're gonna have a hard time convincing
other people that really you have secure
software so it's just better to do it in
the open that's where everyone can go
and see for themselves do you feel like
you've noticed a sea change in this area
I know that you know in certain decades
prior a lot of companies kept their
cards really close to their chests its
proprietary we don't want anyone to see
the source code we don't you know I have
seen like a big change at Microsoft in
just the four years that I've been here
I think I came in just at the right time
when the mentalities were changing and
it's been just getting better and better
I found that I can use a Linux computer
to do my day-to-day work and I can post
on github I don't have to worry about
anything and I think it's just a reality
of software development now that some
software that you depend on is open
source that they're just more productive
if you can contribute back and we have
done that occasionally in my day-to-day
work I use an open source project
there's a bug in it fine I'll go and fix
it and it's just a better way to work
and maybe somebody else has found your
bug and helped you out there
oh yeah and people can come and
sometimes report bugs on our stuff they
should be kind of star for instance we
have contributors people we've never met
we just come in out of the blue and
submit improvements and for us that's
just so thank you very much it's yeah
we're very happy with that and it just
makes you feel better when you wake up
in the morning and you have someone who
just fixed one of your bucks how much
that would happen to me
not software but you know Jonathan
you're working on security and
verification in software and you know
the realities we've talked a little bit
about how scary that world is and you're
working on it every day is there
anything that keeps you up at night
particularly as it pertains to the state
of software that you haven't discussed
already and what should we be aware of I
think the general awareness of the
fragility of software is not as it
should be what I mean by that is there
seems to be in my opinion too much of an
enthusiasm for software without the
awareness of what this entails it's
Christmas season people are gonna get
gifts and I'm being bombarded with smart
appliances every time I see one of these
I'm wondering what are the consequences
and so far it's kind of the Wild West
you should think about all the IOT
things that are going to be spread out
all across the world what's going to
happen to these devices who is going to
maintain the software who is even going
to look at the software before it's
released and sold in millions and it's
actually happening faster than we
realize and that's something that keeps
me up at night
I see everyone getting smart lightbulbs
what if your light bulb is being taken
over by someone else I'm very worried
about these things but I'm also hoping
that soon enough there will be a change
both in terms of the software and also
in terms of expectations and that could
be you know people just don't want
broken software or maybe there's a
regulation that says you can't put on
the market something that is obviously
broken and that's going to be actually a
threat when I talked to Ben it was
actually a year ago we talked about the
Internet of Things and how many devices
get put out in the world and the key is
verification and that was when he
alluded to Everest how is that project
informing this world of devices that are
quote-unquote smart and unverified what
I would hope for at least is that by the
time we managed to get a working version
of meteor as then it can become a viable
option say you're doing a
smart security camera and of course you
need to upload the cloud on the server
well hopefully BTS can be a viable
option for people who want to establish
a secure channel between the writable
device and the cloud that won't solve
every problem far from it but I really
firmly believe in one break at a time
and one step at a time my hope is that
we have at least a better break in that
big software ecosystem one way to sum it
up is software has consequences and
everyone needs to be aware of it
software is not benign software could do
all sorts of terrible things and it
hardly ever does but we need to be
cognizant of the fact that it could and
we need to exercise caution you install
an app think twice you're getting a
smart appliance also think twice but the
problem is the binary option you know do
you agree if you don't you can't have
the app so I hit agree yes and for me
that's the big question like how do we
create the social and economic dynamic
for better software and for me that's a
big open question because I'm just like
you I click on agree all the time I
couldn't like go into existential mode
whenever I install an app so yes I do
click on agree but where is the
incentive going to come from for
internet security the interesting bit is
that there's a big economic incentive if
you're broken people are gonna have to
be paged on a weekend there's going to
be like an incidence response a crisis
so this resonates very well with the
people that we work with and that's why
they're ready for better software what
is the equivalent for all these devices
and the security if that's after I think
that's something we need to figure out
and it can come from many different
places but my hope is that ultimately
yes there is an incentive to make
software in general more secure Jonathan
tell us a bit about yourself
academically and otherwise what's your
story how did you come to be working in
software engineering research at MSR
what don't people know about Jonathan
protsenko I did my PhD in France I
didn't real and as often times happens
at the end of one's PhD I was pretty fed
up by at the end of my
citation writing and I wasn't sure what
I wanted to do with my life I had a lot
of existential moments and I was ready
to quit research and go work in software
because I thought research was too hard
and then my PhD advisor really nuts me
and said well Jonathan at least her
Microsoft research you know you might
find a good vibe there so I did and
that's how I arrived here I didn't
believe in it at first I didn't think I
would make it
I remember chatting with my advisor
about it being like come on Francois
they're never gonna take me but I tried
and yes they did take me so that was
good and I started out as a postdoc here
I worked in a variety of projects and
then I became a researcher after a year
and a half I think and I've been here
for four years now prior to that you did
your PhD in France did you grow up in
France yes I did grow up in France I'm a
pure product of the French system
because you keep talking about
existential moments and it's like oh
don't pull soft where are you from in
France I grew up near Bordeaux stayed in
Bordeaux for high school and it my
master's degree in Neil and then my ph.d
program in Paris nice what's your future
goal aside from conquering Everest where
do you see yourself in five years
oh that's a tough question I didn't give
me a heads-up for that one otherwise
they would have thought about it I'm
hoping that in five years I can start
tackling more fundamental questions
about software about the things that you
are talking about social consequences of
software and that they can bring greater
awareness of what is software what
happens with it and that we can bring
the message of software matters beyond
just the niche areas where people have
come to a conclusion already in make
people more aware of what software
entails and maybe that's where the
incentive to have better software is
going to come from from better software
literacy you're likely going to be
dealing with computers almost every
single day of your life so you need a
little bit of computer literacy you need
people to understand how software works
because that's actually an essential
skill in the modern world and maybe
eventually before aware enough that
they're going to start demanding better
software and hopefully we'll be there as
we close give us an idea this will sound
like a large question but you can scale
it down if you like what's left to
discover or solve in the field of
research in software engineering what
advice or encouragement would you give
to listeners who might be interested or
inspired by the work you're doing one
thing to keep in mind is that we're
getting a lot of people to use our
software our software runs in Firefox
our software runs in Windows this is
great and hopefully soon it will run in
Linux so it all seems wonderful from an
outsider's perspective but it's a lot of
hard work and it's not as easy as it
sometimes seems so we need a lot of help
and I think the next one's here is how
can we make this more usable how can we
make it more accessible to people who
don't have the luxury of spending you
know almost a decade training in
computer science and who will still be
writing software for a living how can we
bring the technology to the masses of
programmers that are out there and I
think that's enormous challenge and any
help would be most welcome Jonathan
Franco thanks for joining us today it's
been really fun special thanks for
having me
[Applause]
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Jonathan Pratt
Zenko and how researchers are trying to
summit the verification mountain so you
don't have to visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]